my name is Carl Jenkins
I understand there's been a lot of
interest in me sir Carl Jenkins a guest
at King Charles's coronation setting the
record straight after the internet's
wild conspiracy theory has gone viral
I'm quite surprised that some people
thought it was very remarkable in
Disguise yep the composer seated second
row at the Royal occasion had fans
convinced he was Meghan Markle in
Disguise and now he's clearing up how he
scored an invite said because I've been
some music
or service
and his grown mustache he's got receipts
debunking speculation of Megan going
incognito I'm a massage has been
referred to in the in the times as well
um
but I've had the Mustang since I was 18
years old it was very trendy then so
that's me there's nothing Sinister about
it that's surprising at all
Megan stayed back in the U.S while her
husband Prince Harry made the trip alone
the fact that he's going solo seems
surprising Until you realize that it's
actually his son Archie's birthday the
very same day so Megan is in fact going
to be staying home in California to
celebrate that birthday which is perhaps
quite convenient given the tensions
between the two families right now I
think it probably was a wise decision by
the Deacon Duchess of Sussex for Harry
to come over and Megan to stay behind us
I think had she come had she come with
the children I think there was always
the risk that that sort of the Sussex
show could have overshadowed the
coronation whether Meg and the kiddos
Archie and Lila bit had a chance between
the birthday celebration to catch any of
the coronation yeah I think for Prince
Harry it's really important that his
children are aware of the world in which
that they are part of of course they are
prince and princess and whilst the time
difference would have made it really
difficult to show the children of the
coronation ceremony live I would imagine
that at some point over the weekend some
effort would have been made to show them
what was going on on the other side of
the Atlantic I think it's something of a
positive Omen that Harry's here I mean
of course he didn't have to come and I
think had he not come that would have
been a riff that we would have said was
was that was it you know there was no
coming back from this but I think every
time he comes here every time there is a
family-owned moment that that forges
away for a Reconciliation certainly with
his father but I think in terms of his
relationship with his brother that's
going to be much harder while Harry made
it to his dad's big day he was spotted
heading out early to catch a flight
seemingly to spend time with little
Archie and his fam Archie's fourth
birthday proceedings would have no doubt
taken place during the day whilst Harry
was on that flight back to California
but he did make it home in time for the
early evening in Montecito probably to
tuck his little son into bed just in
time before the end of the day and I
think that that's probably the moment
that would have made all that rushing
backwards and forwards completely worth
it because he wanted to be able to sort
of honor and acknowledge both of his
families on the day
foreign